hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from last year's FID World
rapid Championship it's a game between
Ral mov and danil Duo you guys have been
requesting a lot of Duo games and as
he's not very active lately I decided to
show you one from last year's uh World
rapid Championship uh if you still
haven't seen his games from the same
event against Anish giri and against
Nial sarin do check them out even before
checking out this video will be the
first and second link in the description
below uh an absolute Master Class by Duo
but I decided to show another one at but
before I do that I would just like to
congratulate the winners of yesterday's
sorry not that of Yer yesterday's
multivers X Christmas Arena uh first
place was won by a German Grandmaster
Matias blue bom second place uh by um a
Mexican Grandmaster Jose Martinez
Alcantara in third place by Vietnamese
Grandmaster Min Le uh with some other
very very strong players competing there
was over
300 well exactly 3001 3,164 players and
even even the great Ali got only seventh
place so it was a really really strong
tournament uh time format was 1 plus
zero and uh multix contributed over
$25,000 uh price fund uh for this event
so thank you for that and hopefully we
can make a similar event next year maybe
even a greater one maybe one that can
last maybe throughout an entire year and
then it can be crowned with like a big
one uh you know before Christmas but
we'll see you know who knows what 2024
will bring uh getting back to this game
really a wild one but I do hope by now
that you've already checked out the
first and second link in the description
below as those games are out of this
world uh let's check it out so R has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
E4 we have Pawn to C5 and now Pawn to C3
going for the alapin Sicilian uh so you
will uh uh prepare Pawn to D4 before
just advancing it to D4 and here top
moves are D5 and KN to F6 but du goes E6
he prepares Pawn to D5 and now just
Knight to F3 and I thought it'd be a
nice way to prepare for the upcoming
world rapid and Blitz Championship that
starts in two days we have Pawn to D5
and pawn to D5 is such a natural move to
make in any opening if your opponent has
a Pawn on C3 it's what we are thought as
children as uh the the pawn already
occupies a natural Square for the Knight
so even if you capture with something
like the queen here you don't have
Knight to C3 to kick away the queen but
du doesn't capture back with the queen
he actually plays e captures and D5 even
though Queen captures is the top move or
rather the most popular one uh D4 we
have Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5
so okay this fairly standard stuff been
played hundreds of times uh we have
castles and now Knight to E7 much better
than Knight to F6 for example allowing
white this very natural developing move
for the bishop so Knight E7 uh D capes
and C5 sort of making black waste the
tempo here uh Bishop captures and now
Knight beat to D2 uh we have castles and
now Knight to B3 attacking the bishop
Bishop B6 and Bishop back to B3 again
Alin play before nothing new here and
Duo plays Pawn to H6 here he just wants
to be a bit uh well sort of extra safe
here but it's a very instructive
position uh for that you can use in your
own games because it really does look
like let's say what black plays a weird
move it really does look like you have a
classic Bishop sacrifice here with
Knight G5 Queen to H5 and then check
mating the black king but something that
can help you for example in your own
blizz games is that black has control
over df5 square and as long as that uh
is so uh the the sacrifice doesn't work
point being that after captures captures
check King to G8 and queen to H5 you
don't have Checkmate due to Bishop to F5
uh and as long as you have that you
don't have to worry about this classic
sacrifice next he'll play Bishop G6 kick
away the queen and everything is fine
black is just winning so of course H6
here by dubove and now uh Bishop to F4
it was it's not a new move today as the
position has all already been reached a
few times after this game was played but
back when it was played Bishop to F4 was
a new move so it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game uh we
have Bishop to G4 dub of being annoying
here preventing the knight from moving
we have Pawn to H3 Bishop to H5 and now
Bishop back to E2 you could consider
some other moves like you could move the
bishop back to C2 to maybe try and put
some pressure here or maybe just keep
the tension with Rook D1 H but it's a
rapid game of course you don't want U
you you don't want this annoying Bishop
harassing your queen uh all game so Rook
to E8 Rook to E1 and now Knight to G6
putting pressure on the bishop here and
Bishop back to G3 both players playing
very very natural moves Queen to D7 du
of develops the queen just connects the
Rooks uh Knight F to D4 offering some
trades on the d square and now even
Bishop captures on E2 Rook captures with
Rook captures on E2 Queen captures and
Knight captures on D4 Knight captures
Bishop captures and pawn captures so A
beautiful capture Fest here and it does
seem like a good idea to play like this
against um a player like dubo that
really thrives in complex positions and
you know with with Madness on the board
uh Rook to E8 getting the Rook to the
open E file with Tempo the queen is
attacked Queen to D2 and now Knight to
E7 and this is a very good move by dubov
and you should always look for Moves
Like These in your own games it's a
basically an idea of creating a game
plan what what is your game plan and
du's game plan is that he wants to get
the Knight over to C6 to attack the D4
pawn and he's going to pile up on it
with something like Rook to E4 and maybe
later on even with the queen uh and
that's a very good thing because this is
a weakness and this is also a weakness
the difference between the two
weaknesses is that the dub of's Knight
can attack the D4 Pawn however Ralph's
Bishop cannot attack the D5 Pawn it's a
dark Square bishop and it's a Pawn on a
light Square so also something to
consider whenever you you know you're
figuring out a game plan it usually
involves something with the Knight and
maybe even going back with the Knight so
knight t7 uh Rook to C1 and now Knight
to C6 just nicely puts pressure on the
D4 pawn and ra says yeah I can't really
allow that pawn to F3 just stops Rook to
E4 also frees up the F2 square if the
pawn will need more protection we have
Queen to F5 by dubove now maybe even
considering Shifting The Rook over uh to
to the C8 square and Bishop to F2 uh we
have Pawn to A6 and now Pawn to A4
stopping Pawn to B5 Rook to E6 Duo says
all right you prevented me from going
after this Pawn but maybe I can go after
your king uh Pawn to B4 and now Duo
stops Pawn to B5 by advance ing the pawn
to B5 himself we have captures captures
and now Rook to C5 going after the B5
pawn and how can dubov stop this well he
finds a very active way of doing it and
again it involves a move with the Knight
back he plays Knight to E7 and now how
does uh this move actually stop Rook
captures on B5 well if Rook captures on
B5 now you have this annoying Queen to
B1 check and now D1 square is covered by
the queen and the Rook so you can't
really block you have to play King H2
and then Queen F1 preparing Rook to E2
uh while attacking The Rook on B5 uh
looks annoying uh to say the least okay
you can free It Up by playing Rook B8
check then maybe putting pressure on the
Knight here uh but maybe allowing black
a bit too much so he just plays Queen to
C2 he offers the queen trade and
interestingly Duo accepts Queen captures
Rook captures and now he plays Rook to
C6 he stops the annoying Rook to C5 move
uh we have Rook back to E2 uh he doesn't
want to trade Rooks here as uh well the
pawns are on light sores the bishop will
not really be able to go after the the
pawns whereas the Knight will be able to
go after the B4 and D4 pawns but still
it's probably probably best thing to do
Rook to E2 was played going after the
Knight and now Rook to C1 with check uh
we have King to H2 and now we have um uh
well I'm not going to tell you what du
of played here uh but this was basically
the the first mistake of the game and
it's one that cost around the game here
you should just block and that's it even
with with the DU spawns and light
squares let's see you trade here
captures captures and Knight F5 goes
after the pawn you will defend it and
then slowly but surely bring your king
if um you know it's needed to help out
with the defense of the B4 Pawn but you
could also just leave the King on the
king side let's say put the bishop here
and there there's no good way for the
black king to infiltrate this position
it's uh uh there's just no way in so
that was the way to go but he played
King to H2 instead and now I will allow
you guys to win this game for d because
it's uh it's uh well very instructive so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only way only path to victory
for danil while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the the weakness and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Knight to C6 there is no way of
defending the B4 Pawn and B4 is such an
important Square you should always have
it defended unless you're you know
sacrificing it um by choice and now the
problem is if you play something like
Rook to B2 then you just pile up and
there's no way to defend you will lose
that pawn so here Ralph tried something
else he played Rook to E8 with check
King H7 and now Rook to C8 stopping
Knight captures on B4 as The Rook on C1
is hanging but du just plays Rook to C2
now Knight captures will defend his Rook
uh but still it's only it's only a pawn
can can this really be enough for a win
King to G1 we have Rook to C1 with check
here they repeated once King to G1 and
now he captured Knight captures on B4 so
you cannot trade uh an extra Pawn in in
a bishop versus night end game
especially with the pawn already being
so far Advanced would be winning for
dubove so here Rook to B8 was played
going after the B5 Pawn but now look at
this Knight D3 uh freeing up uh the the
B4 Square for the pawn to occupy uh with
tempo as the bishop on F2 is hanging so
Bishop G3 and now Pawn to B4 uh King to
F1 Rook to B2 now preparing to advance
the pawn to B3 which is a light square
and now the uh King F1 was a nice active
move but it also allows dubu to uh to
continue pushing the pawn in the sense
after Bishop to D6 putting pressure on
the pawn B3 and Bishop to A3 attacking
The Rook he has this freeing Rook to F2
check and now the pawn will reach B2 so
King to G1 Pawn to B2 but even with all
of this and with the dubo being up a
pawn how does he actually play B1 Pawn
to B1 with the Rook guarding the B1
Square you can't really move the Rook
ever to to the back rank because then
he'll just capture the pawn of course
the king will not remain on the on the
back rank to allow a rook let's say to
come to C1 with check so how do you do
it well let's see that's what we are
here for King H2 of course the king does
not belong on a back rank anymore uh
Rook to C2 by dubov and okay just King
to G3 we said that you cannot go to G1
because of a simple check and then the
pawn queen so King to G3
uh and now comes Pawn to G5 so now this
is no longer a game of advancing the
pass B Pawn okay that's a weakness but
usually to win a game you need more than
one you need a it's sort of everyone
calls it the principle of two weaknesses
so this is one weakness in White's camp
and a second one needs to be created and
the second one will be of course trying
to Checkmate the the white king uh Rook
to B7 going after F7 now King to G6 we
have Rook to B6 with check and pawn to
F6 and you don't have time for uh Bishop
to F6 as you you really do need that B
Pawn defended so here we have Rook to
back to B7 Pawn to H5 now we have Rook
to B6 and now King to F7 uh Rook to B7
with check King to G6 and now Rook to B6
and dub uh decides uh to go for a very
interesting idea and that is King to F5
he actually allows Bishop to E7 and Rook
captures an F6 to come with check so
okay Bishop to E7 uh you don't have to
worry the B1 square is defended still by
by the rook and you might have time to
capture it with check and bring the Rook
back this would go a long way for black
uh if it's enough but now H4 check uh
freeing up df4 square for the black king
this is crucial King H2 and now King to
F4 and okay you have nothing better Rook
captures an F6 with check King to E3 and
now Rook to E6 with check King to F2 and
now Rook to B6 again stopping promotion
uh but here duu just played King to F1
and he was in this position un move 57
that RAF m resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh there is
no defense against Rook captures on G2
followed by Knight to F2 Checkmate so
even with this little material on the
board dubov manages to find a way to
Checkmate the black king it's just I
mean it's just what he does uh of course
let's say Bishop A3 it seems like you've
paralyzed Black's pieces because uh you
can't move any otherwise you're going to
lose the pawn and you cannot Advance
because the Rook covers the B1 square
but it's a matter of the simple Rook
captures with check uh only King H1 and
Knight F2 will be Checkmate so brilliant
brilliant game by dubov uh mov only made
one one mistake when he allowed dubov to
to grab that B Pawn but it was enough
for dubov to take the whole point and
yeah dubov played incredibly well he
finished uh fourth I think let me just
check I don't want to trick you guys uh
let me just check yeah he finished
fourth yeah Magnus was clear first with
10 out of 13 Vincent Cameron Fabiano
Carana 9 and a half out of 13 second and
third place and dubove fourth place with
N Out of 13 well it's a shared for
fourth with many uh but um a better
additional criteria so we'll see what
happens in this world rapid and Blitz
Championship can we expect more
brilliancies from dubov uh and can he
can he play a you know brilliant chess
and dazzling chess while also scoring
points uh is uh is you know remains to
be seen But if you haven't seen the
games that I mentioned in the beginning
of the video also from this event Duo
versus Anan Duo versus versus um Nial
sarin first and second link in the
description below I mean it's uh you
know you could spend your day worse uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again congratulations to
the winner of yesterday's multivers X
Christmas Arena I hope it's it's the
second one we also had one last year but
hope it's not the last one we'll see how
it goes I would like to thank Kenneth F
niola VC Maximo Ean Amilia gray Scott
and Sven fer for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day